hi this is Thomas flight with another
quick video si one of the things I love
most about film as a medium is that a
filmmaker can use the visual language of
a film to let you see the progression of
the story like this moment in The
Godfather where Michael has to make a
phone call about his father this phone
call ends up being the incident that
will change things for Michael forever
and his physical separation from his
girlfriend kay in the shot as he makes
the call for shadows the relational
separation that begins at this moment it
never has to be called attention to or
stated explicitly and the audience might
not even notice it but subconsciously it
reinforces the story visually but the
Godfather isn't the Al Pacino film I'm
going to talk about in this video let's
take a look at the panic in needle park
and how it uses a triptych to visually
mark the progressions in the story
spoilers ahead the panic in needle part
follows the story of Helen a homeless
girl whose friendship and romance was
Bobby leads her into heroin addiction
director Jerry shots Berg uses three key
shots to bookmark each major moment in
the arc of the story in the first key
shot we see Helen alone on the train
this shot establishes for us her problem
she's on her own and unlike the people
crowded around her moments before she
has nowhere to go nowhere to be
then Helen meets Bobby and their
relationship solve some of her problems
but she eventually gives in to the
temptation of the constant exposure and
availability of heroin
I'm not looking just chipping then we
get the second key shot towards the
middle of the thing we can see the
closeness of their relationship and the
seriousness of her decision to step
fully into Bobby's world it shows us how
their romantic relationship is
inseparably linked to Helens drug use we
can see her shame and Bobby's dread as
he knows what the future holds and how
in a tragic way now that she's using
they can finally share a big part of
Bobby's life and they're closer than
they've ever been but the story doesn't
end there as the film progresses their
drug use starts to supersede their
relationship and in a final attempt to
escape from heroine and by extension
Bobby
Helen ends up betraying him and ratting
him out to the police
the last key shot and the final shot of
the film alludes to the finality of this
progression
Barbie
as Helen chases Bobby it's clear that
any remnant of love has long been
overshadowed by the damaged heroine has
done to their relationship
Hellen seeks forgiveness for her
betrayal but as her relationship with
Bobby became inseparable from her
relationship with heroin we realized her
reunion with Bobby probably means her
return to using
when you look at all these shots
together as a triptych you can see the
whole arc of the story Helen is drawn to
Bobby out of need and love that romance
leads her to drug use and finally
they're together
but no semblance of love remains their
relationship is both destroyed and held
together by their mutual need for a fix
when I think of the panic in needle park
I think of these three shots they dug
into my brain and they didn't let go but
what makes these shots stick out the
first key shot is a long shot that holds
after a series of a few shorter shots
this combined with its focus on a single
subject amidst the turmoil and motion
causes the moment istic in the minds of
the viewer the second shot is also a
longer shot but it most obviously
signals to the audience the significance
in the moment by cutting from a very
wide angle to an extreme close-up this
close-up is the closest the camera has
ever been to their faces together and
it's the most intimate moment we
experience between them to further
emphasize this particular moment the
noise of the street falls away the final
shot starts with an empty frame then
reveals the two characters we've been
focused on and care about slowly
answering the questions we all have in
our minds what will happen to Bobby and
Helen will their relationship work
notice how what clues we get towards the
answer come from the blocking of the
city it's a long shot when it cuts to
black the image of the two of them
sticks in your mind
you can form triptychs like this from
other films as well
returning to the Godfather we can use
three key shots to show the main arc of
the story often the memorable shots from
a film are memorable simply because they
looked but what if you can use single
shots to give the audience signposts
along the way a movie is experienced
linearly as you watch it and all at once
as you remember it and I think a good
director knows how to craft a film that
will be powerful both as you experience
it and as you think back over it in the
hours and days after watching it when
you can form triptychs like these out of
shots from the film it speaks to the
strength of the visual storytelling this
video is brought to you by my patreon
supporters and if you're interested in
supporting my patreon it would go a long
way to helping me continue making these
videos for a long time to come in
addition when you support my patreon you
get extra material like follow-up blog
posts I do and the occasional or movie
review and more I appreciate every
viewer and comment and if you're new
don't forget to subscribe and I'll see
you again next time